so I'm going to show how one can extend
the current geometry features in 10 to
compute augen values over what really
are arbitrary regions are eigenvalues of
elliptical operators over these regions
so as you've all seen in 10 of course
one can now do pdes over very
complicated regions this is a fairly
simple one right and it's fast ok so
it's quick and easy to solve say the
Laplace equation over this kind of
domain but currently with built-in
methods I could not solve the eigen
value problem over this domain so you
can use the geometry features to do that
but you have to do a little work
yourself and basically what i've done is
i've implemented right really the usual
finite element method for the eigen
value problem here so right we have a
differential equation here that we want
to solve over some region right script
are ok and right we generate the weak
form of that equation where piece of ass
is some test function ok and I'll
discretize are with first order
triangular elements so on each element
we approximate the function sigh by some
alpha I of x and y times sigh I where
sigh I write is linear in X and Y and
the a eyes are given by these
combinations right we're right this will
refer xiy I and so on right and depend
on the vertexes ok and so we can write
the alpha I is right like so where a is
the area of each triangular element ok
so this is just the usual finite element
method and then i'm going to pick my
test function as
alpha of x and y okay so the whole trick
is we can compute these on a reference
triangle this is what's normally done in
finite elements and then we'll push that
across the vertices of all our mesh okay
and we can do this as a essentially
vector operation okay so it's very fast
and efficient so the end result is that
for each element right we have a
equation which looks like this we're
right s sub right Delta here indicates
that this is the integral over the
triangle right and here's T which is
also integrated over each triangle ok so
the esses and Delta R and T sub
triangles are all three by three
matrices okay so for each mesh right for
each triangle we're going to get a three
by three matrices matrix these are local
matrices and then they have to be
assembled into a global matrix right smt
with no subscript here okay and these
will be n by n matrices where n is the
total number of nodes angry and then we
go ahead and we solve the generalized
eigenvalue problem right SI is equal to
K squared T sigh so right okay so let's
look at an example and I picked a
hexagon as an example because I have
colleagues who sit next to me at the
University of Cincinnati and some in
Australia who do not sit next to me
obviously who grow and study they're
actually grown in Australia studied at
the University of Cincinnati among other
places what are known as course shell
nanowires and these are more or less
hexagonal okay so here we have a hexagon
I just generate the the boundary points
and then i compute I form a boundary
mesh region okay from this hexagon and
then I have to tell it right
what order I'm traversing things in and
of course right I have to close it up ok
so i generate that ok and ok i can then
generate a mesh so i can triangulate it
this course is normally one of the hard
parts of finite element but i'll just
let write the function triangulate mesh
do that here i set the mesh quality goal
right to matt small one can do in fact
much more much finer mesh if you like
and we will need to later ok and i also
need to compute the boundary mesh
because i'll need to specify right the
boundary values at the boundary so so
here i'm showing you the mesh right the
red are all the free points ok the free
vertices everything in black will be
specified by the boundary values right
and they're all right numbered here as
well so not only does do the new
geometry functions make it easy to
specify mesh they also make it easy to
visualize it and play with it so what do
I have to do now that I have my mesh
well I have to compute right the alphas
essentially right and right so the code
is more or less literally a translation
of what was on the first slide a written
so that we can push this right across
the elements here right and compute
right s for each triangle so this SEL
here is the element matrix for each
triangle and TL is the element is also
the element matrix for each triangle and
add this actually depends only on the
area of the triangle ok so right our
triangle areas
computed here it's just a long list we
can then simply compute t for the whole
thing okay so we now have to assemble a
global matrix and this is best
understood okay with a little example
right so I made a very tiny mesh region
here to make it easier to understand how
Li assembly is done a right so I've got
12 right okay three four triangles which
are labeled here and then the vertices
are shown in red okay so the two here
indicates dimensions so that's going to
label the triangles 0 of course we'll
label the vertices ok so I'll extract
the mesh cells from this mesh ok right
so that extracts the polygons ok then I
can extract a set of indices from those
just by right getting rid of the polygon
so these are the indices so for instance
my first triangle right 125 ok second
triangle is right 2 3 4 and so on I'll
need a list of global indices right
which I can get simply by taking the
outer product right of the indices ok
and then write a check right the
dimensions of that ok so the dimensions
of the global right are right we've got
four because we've got four triangles
each of them are three by threes ok and
in order to assemble our global matrix
ok the rule is that s IJ element so II
here stands for element s and the I and
J stand for the vertices for the indexes
of the element matrix so this is each of
these or three by threes the
get mapped to N of I ailment in of j
ailment okay where any I for instance is
the global node number index by the
element number and the local number
right so n of two three is five since
that's the number of the second node of
the third element if we go around right
counterclockwise okay so this is just
really a replacement rule so it's fairly
simple to write in Mathematica okay and
I've got a little function called
generate matrix which does that ok and
now right we just bundle up the code and
the code looks kind of bad and long but
right this is just essentially standard
okay the standard finite element stuff
the function right here right called
coordinates right simply fishes out the
three by three coordinates right the
coordinates of each little triangle okay
bye right right by looking at the mesh
cells and then picking out the mesh
coordinates of those cells and bundling
them up right so that you've got the
cells of each triangle okay or the
coordinates of each triangle so this is
an old slow machine okay but even on
this old slow machine for the mess you
saw this took point two seconds so it's
really quite fast okay right now one
thing that that's happening here okay is
that all the right right if you look
closely you'll see that i have things
labeled free points right and then their
boundary points so when i generate this
large matrix capital s and capital T
okay I then decimate it along the from
the boundaries okay so that I remove
those entries and that way when I'm
solving right for the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors a I'm solving a smaller so
system hey the small element matrices
right SEL and TL are generated as sparse
matrices a sense right they get
essentially blown up to n by n dimension
and then added together to generate the
full matrices and now here I've plotted
below for instance the right the ground
state here right for my hexagon okay now
actually when they grow these nanowires
are not really hexagonal and so could we
do better okay so here we have right so
the ultimate goal actually is to do this
from a TM high-resolution tem pictures
okay but to see if it worked I simply
sketched this right on a piece of paper
my office and photographed it okay so
here we've got a core-shell nanowire
grown by a particularly inept graduate
student and my collaborators assured me
that fire such graduate student grew
something like this okay and in a real
course shell nanowire what you have is
there's a potential here that's
different from the potential here so
we'll want to be able to put a potential
on the center there so okay if I was
really good at image processing then I
would write simply use the image
processing tools in Mathematica to
extract the boundaries okay I'm not
really good at image processing and i
found that okay I had to laborious Lee
tweaked the code for each particular
case hey to really get at the boundaries
so what I did was I simply click the
points off the boundaries okay hey those
were the long numbers at right
you saw it takes you know two minutes or
so it's really straightforward okay i
right I make it sickly by adding the
right the first point at the end ok so I
get sick like boundaries ok so right
here's my hair my two boundaries ok well
are the points that represent the two
boundaries since they're nice and cyclic
right I can simply go ahead and use
boundary mesh region ok to generate
boundary meshes for those so I have to
give it the list of points and then of
course I have to tell it what right how
low should be connected ok the other
thing one has to do is of course to
scale the data because this has been
right essentially right just grabbed off
a picture ok so I scaly so that I can
put them together ok and the scaling is
done right so that the x coordinates lie
between x-men and xmax ok and then I'll
show you right so we scale the boundary
regions ok and right and triangulate ok
so there's the outer regions right
gotten from my picture and triangulated
ok and I need to be able to pick out the
mesh cells that are in the inner
boundary because they're going to have a
potential on them ok so I'll generate a
region member function ok and then I'll
simply call you in that region if for
example you're set the centroid is
inside the region ok so if you're a
triangle we compute your centroid if
it's inside the region you're in
otherwise you're out ok so this gives us
for instance the cells in the region ok
and this is still relatively small
example so right there they are and we
can get the cell
ordinance from them a and right we need
these to compute the areas of the cells
okay so here for example are some of our
cells that lie in the region okay and I
can visualize that right by making these
graphics objects so here we go I'll
combine them with the outer boundary
region hey so you can see of course we
do particularly poorly because right
when our have enough polygons okay so
right we need to do better than that
okay in fact i'll show you the right
here's the boundary we're trying to
approximate right so we want to refine
the mesh but we only want to refine the
mesh around this boundary right we don't
want to refine the mesh everywhere that
just wastes polygons right and this will
lead to a much larger matrix to find the
eigenvalues of right so we'll write a
mesh refinement function okay which
usually is the region distance and
region difference here which says you
know if you're close to this black line
i want to refine the mesh and so then
will triangulate the mesh again and
right here you see we've got a much
denser mesh in here we haven't done
anything out here the refined mesh does
write a much better job right so here we
have the boundary points on which right
that I extracted from the picture a
shown in green and red and now right all
we need to do now is to put a potential
on okay I'll need the dimension a ok and
right so I just pick out the selected
cells the area of the selected cells
okay since my potential is constant
right it's piecewise constant the matrix
elements here are just my old key
element up to write a constant okay so
basically it's already been computed and
all I have to do is to multiply by that
okay do that for the whole thing then
set a potential a so now if I wish a new
potential right I only have to change
one number i don't have to do any
computing so i bundled all this together
right and we run it and it doesn't take
very much time okay and and this does
take a second or so and if I don't rerun
it for some odd reason i get this
cluster integration label here which i
do not understand but ok nevertheless it
it works so right here we see the
excited states okay and i'm only showing
you right the first five or so if I need
more states of course right as i move up
in state my error gets worse so i'm
going to need write a finer mesh one can
also do this with a potential it's not
constant okay simply by saying well my
polygons are small it's constant over
that polygon right so i'll just write
take the value of it at the centroid ok
and then map that across my polygons
instead of mapping a constant potential
ok takes essentially the same amount of
computation time you only have to be
sure that right your polygons are small
enough so that the potential doesn't
really vary in the largest of the
polygons that you have in your
calculation and if that's not true then
you're going to have to refine the
polygons one could of course write a
mesh refinement
function which depended on your
potential and thus right automatically
ensured that the polygons were refined
according to the change in the potential
if necessary and one I've done this for
the Schrodinger equation you could do
this for other equations I'm using
linear right right interpolation and
triangles right it would be better to
use quadratic interpolation you'd get
right much better results in terms of
accuracy but I haven't done that yet